do
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of talking germany
the show where we do just that and my
guest today
is a very special man indeed at an early
age he contracted polio but despite
that handicap and maybe even because of
it he became an extremely
accomplished dancer and here he is in
person
degeneres hello wonderful to have you
here today dergan coming to join us here
on talking germany thank you very very
much
indeed now when i say that dergin togmac
is is accomplished it's a massive
understatement he is i can tell you
absolutely breathtaking and his skill on
his sticks as he calls his crutches
has helped him to build a high-flying
career that has included a world tour
with the giants of circus
the cirque du soleil now
again i'd like to begin with something
that you told me before the show when we
were chatting a little bit
you were saying that your first language
more or less is german
your second language is turkish your
third language
is english and your fourth language is
dance
correct yeah i thought it was really
interesting tell me how important dance
is to you
oh dancing is very important for me
because of i'm a very like a
a person who is have lots of energy and
i think it's uh
gives me the situ giving me uh the
chance like to really fill us off with
my body
yeah so and it helps me also like bring
my
my mind and my body together so it's
very important for me in my life
okay it's been very important for you in
your very successful professional life
because you are a very
a very successful dancer tell me did
have you become a dancer did you become
a dancer
because this is the question i asked in
my introduction a little bit did you
become a dancer
uh despite your disability or perhaps
even because of your disability
well um i found a solution you know how
to like create my own style and you know
in dance which is very important is uh
you need to really be unique you know if
you want to be successful
and in my case uh brings my handicap
it makes me like unique in that you know
like so i think i was taking a big
advantage of this
of my disability yeah to you know
integrate myself
uh with my dance it
and make it successful yeah and we we
need to
talk we're going to talk a lot a little
bit later in depth about this whole the
whole idea of handicapping being
handicapped and not being handicapped
and what that means
just tell me about the whole idea of
being handicapped because
you i mean you are as a person you're
much more athletic
than i am yeah you're much more mobile
than i am so in what sense are you a
handicapped person
do you view yourself as a handicapped
person
well i think we all have a handicap
somewhere you know like and we need to
just find out where is the handicap and
then
you can like work on that and make
enough progress how like
how to how to make it the best of it you
know and
uh and uh you know it's it's
it's always it's difficult you know but
uh
but it's uh you know it's it's it's just
like
i found a solution i was always like as
a kid very creative
and i think you know sport was very
important for me as well
you know and mobility is also very very
important for me and i found out
uh you know always like trying some
things out making tricks you know like
and
just like funding always like
challenging myself with the
with the situation you know how can you
go the stairs up you know or how you can
go down you know like how you can
survive in this uh
in this wild jungle in the big cities
and you know dancing is always me and
helps me
also like you know for my from my all
day you know to
how to survive wonderful
again as we learnt in that report you
were born in augsburg
yeah is augsburg still home for you yeah
yeah definitely oxford is like i'm a i'm
a native augsburg
man so i born there and even when i'm
traveling all around the world
it's always i'm coming back to augsburg
so it's my basement there basically
you're you're you're a real homeboy when
you talk about when you talk about your
childhood in augsburg
you quite often mentioned that there was
a lot of pain
and a lot of loneliness yeah can you
describe that a little bit more for us
well i mean when i was starting to found
out that i have polios
so i had to found on a solution how how
i can make the best of it you know like
so it starts with us going to the school
i was going to like a handicapped school
and never really take care of us there
and trying to updating us with all those
uh
things where we can make it better i had
lots of surgeries on my legs i can count
my scars which is like 11 scars
and my parents was always taking the
decision for this you know
in that time they were not speaking very
well german as well so they were like
always uh you know what the doctor was
saying hey we can make here surgery and
make it better
and they were just always like like keep
hoping that i can maybe once i can walk
so and they also were very religious so
they thought maybe we can maybe
like you know go to an iman or to like a
pastor like he make can make it
make it make him feel good you know so
they tried pretty much everything like
to make me feel
to make me walk so it's interesting
you're talking about you're talking
about the difficulties in this very
early phase but you you've mentioned it
already you were you were already
when you even when you were like i think
three four five years old you were
extremely sporty you were extremely i
mean we saw it in those
in that footage there yeah you were very
dynamic yeah
yeah no i was i was as a child i mean
for me was like
everything i saw it more like you know
like a game
and uh you know i mean other normal kids
were starting to walk on the feet
i was starting to walk on my hands and i
was three years old and i found very
like
quick i found out that i'm like very
strong you know like what i didn't have
on my legs i was compensating on my
upper body
so and i mean i was moving and i was
like a normal child i was playing like
everything was pretty normal for me
until like when i was starting to going
uh to find out what to found out what
can i kind of job i can do it
i found it very like difficult in that
time like to
my for everyone is difficult to be a you
know this
step from going from school and then
like doing your profession for
for work yeah so in that time i was like
uh
studying a technical illustrator so i
did i had also a normal
life i would say and i but you had the
normal life but what was going on at the
same time you'd seen this movie breaking
which obviously had an impact a massive
impact on you it sort of effectively
changed your life and then you started
you started dancing you started training
yourself and you were working very very
hard
to become a dancer yeah perhaps i i
don't know perhaps you could show us
some of the you know take us back to
those days and show us some of the
sort of the earliest steps i don't know
that you were that you
worked on sure yeah um great
well my first one of my first steps was
like uh
they called the tic tac step well i'm
taking like the right stronger lag
and bring it together with my weaker lag
and this is like one of my basics like
this is maybe the first time when i was
you know really going in a circle and
dancing
like and even as a teenager you were
training like three or four hours a day
oh every day that's the first thing what
i thought when i come back from the
school
yeah i was go right away like just to
this youth youth center where i was
always training
this and we were training hard so every
time
and how did you how you you initially
you didn't tell your parents you sort of
kept it secret from your parents yeah my
parents
were pretty pretty much worried about me
because i can hurt myself and you know
not surprised
yeah show us a bit more yeah um yeah i
want to show you like my early steps
yeah
this was one of from the early steps my
my last step what i really learned in
the circus in the end
like was the handstand to doing on the
crutches okay so i think this is like
the
the high-class move in my whole
repertoire
so i hope i can go up again wait
oh
can you when you were in augsburg back
then and you'd begun to train and you've
begun to learn these initial moves yeah
and you when you had you when you
performed initially
yeah how did people react
oh the reaction it was uh it was
incredible
i was observing this applause like from
my very first time
and this was like give me like you know
the impression like you know i should
work on it you know like because it's a
nice uh
exchange between the audience and the
artists like when they're giving you
you're doing your show and then they're
giving you like a big applause
yeah and this energy gives you like a
really like a big strengths you know you
cannot describe it it's just incredible
this kind of this feeling wonderful good
for you and
the applause gets even bigger because
obviously after later on you went to
you you went to work for the cirque du
soleil we'll talk about that in just a
second
it must make you very sad again to to to
see that there are still countries in
the world where there are
children who are affected by polio
yeah you still can unfortunately you
still can see it like in
other second world or third world
countries you know and also like
um it comes also now to to germany since
all those uh uh people coming from syria
you know like in those children's are
not
getting the vaccine so i so there's like
a little coming back a little bit so we
need to really take care about it and
i have to see that we have this over
control and help those kids you know
so yeah um just give me a little bit of
a help with pronunciation i'm going to
print i'm going to pronounce the name of
a turkish village yeah which is
uh murakai oh yeah okay
yeah really good yeah that was the
village that you too that your parents
took you back to when you were eight
months old
perhaps you can just describe the
village a little bit for us
well it's like a small village in
anatolia in turkey
which is like in the mountains it's very
dry and has like a
i don't know like a water thing so it's
like maybe like 200 people lives there
yeah and i still remember when we used
to go as
my childhood we used to go every year
when we had the school holidays we used
to go always visit my grandmother and my
grandfather
so it's pretty simple there and even
like until to the end of the 80s there
were no
electricity and no water so we had to go
there and just like
bring everything the water and you know
so please people living from there from
what they are
growing so it's pretty simple so
it's a bit ironic really because this
this village is associated with a very
unhappy development in your life but
also with some of the
the happiest moments in your childhood
yeah oh we used to love to go every year
to turkey it was great you know like
because we used to still live in
augsburg
in a city and there and we used to go to
turkey like in the village you you could
play and there were
cars and there were animals you know
it's just like was nice for my childhood
there
you've mentioned you've mentioned to
your parents already and uh
and they're very important to you you
still live close to your parents in
in augsburg uh it must have been a
terrible thing for them
for their for their little baby to
suddenly have been affected by
the polio virus yeah do did you when you
were growing up did you
talk to them about that or did you just
get on with your lives and
well i mean we used to talk sometimes
about it but it was like a chapter
well i just like uh didn't want to
really talk about that so i was like
always trying to look forward
and you know use the situation what i
have and make it the best on it
yeah well they we we've mentioned the
fact that you
uh you you you kept it a little bit of a
secret from them for a while that you
were you had ambitions to be a dancer
i'm curious to know what ambitions they
might have had for you because it's very
interesting because you're clearly a
very very bright guy and they must have
been they must have been sort of
thinking well he could do this or he
could do that yeah well
my father always i was he wants to have
that i'm like studying and like having
like another you know be more focused on
the school but i mean i was not
really a guy i could really sit quiet
and just like study you know so i had
way too much energy in myself and uh you
know
so it was always like secretly i was
always practicing and trying to like you
know go my own way
yeah and i think i have like i'm a
little bit [ __ ] so
and have my you know when i really want
to do something i really
want to do it you know like so i i'm not
the person that listen to other persons
you know listening maybe but
you know i always try to take this out
what i really like to do it and i have
i just have a big uh i don't know a big
heart just like my heart
when i if i listen my heart he always
tells me where to go
sounds wonderful let's just talk about
your crutches for just a second you've
got you've got them here to tell
us about your crutches because i mean
they're very important in your life yeah
yeah they are definitely
yeah yeah yeah well i used to have like
when i was the starters
in the 80s dance i had pretty much
normal crutches but
after a while like you know i found a
way
how to make them like the best so which
is really important on those crutches is
like this one
is in one piece which is a carbon fiber
in
in titanium and the crutch is very light
so they have to be really light here
yeah because i have i've spent a bit a
fair bit of time on crouches myself
because i once
broke my leg extremely badly so these
are very light
indeed yeah yeah i'm very picky with
those crutches so the circus soleil made
me
them as i meet them i gave them a
prototype how to
have to like you have to have to do them
and they just made the the formula one
crutch for me
oh yeah you know you think you can see
also a bandage because when i'm always
going on stage before i go on stage i'm
getting very nervous and sweaty yeah
so that's why i have also here this year
and wrapping every day after
after before i go on stage this down
here this is important because you don't
want to be slipping around at all you
need to have you
you know well depends what what kind of
stages is i'm always changing the tips
so the tips have to be light as well and
also you know
sometimes in clubs it's a bit difficult
but yeah
the stage you have to be like here is
right now the best yeah and i also like
this baton or
concrete concrete yeah is for me
the best so i have the concrete i have
the best feeling to dance okay tell me
this
uh i know that you were for you are
something of a role model yeah
for other people and you get a lot of
you get a lot of mail from people saying
people who maybe are encouraged people
are maybe handicapped in some other way
saying
what you do and how you do it i like it
tell us a little bit about the
about that mail and that that feedback
that you get yeah
no i get that all the time like nice
feedbacks emails or
i also have like some tutorials in
youtube's you know when some people ask
me like hi
hey how do you start or how did it do
this so i put a tutorial on youtube and
also
you know when people are writing me also
i'm writing them back like it gives me a
also a good energy like when i see okay
i'm i'm working for something i'm doing
something good you know like so
it's it's nice to see that how how you
must be very proud of the fact that you
uh that you have this role that you can
be a role model for others that you can
inspire other people
i know it's always hard to be asked
about your pride but i think you must be
here
well i don't know if i'm like of course
i'm proud of her that you know like if
you mean this is what's about the life
you know you need to also think about
other people not just on yourself yeah
you know and
and most people don't do that for me
it's very important to shares you know
and
i think with dance you can you can share
in any languages
so everybody understand it so you know
like
when we're talking about uh dansdurgen
it's uh
you you we've learned already you went
off to work for the cirque du soleil you
worked for
with them for six years yeah in a
program
called varakai let's before you tell us
a little bit more about exactly what
that was all about what it was like
working for the circus let's just have a
glimpse of
a view on stage again yeah because this
is fantastic stuff the cirque du soleil
with darakai
tell us a little bit about the story
tell us about what we're actually seeing
there about the role that you played
there
um the character what i was playing was
the olympian angel and the whole story
was about was about the greek mythology
about icarus
in our story he's not dying it he just
said break his wings
and his legs and we trying to you know
to show him in the show
how is how you can get up you need to
learn when you fall
you need to learn how to get up and this
is like the whole message in my number
i'm one of those
angels and i try inspire icarus
how did it come about how did how did
you get the job in the first place did
the phone ring and they got in touch
with you or
well it was uh in 2003 when uh it was
the first time i was in contact with
cirque du soleil so
um they were making a world worldwide
research like they have a big casting
department where they were looking
they're always replacing uh those
certain of acts
so they had this act they had this act
uh
from from with these scratches and it
was a guy before he was always just
simulating
was this was this a guy a guy called
bill shannon or was that somebody
different he was a choreographer who's
the choreographer he seems to
have been a remarkable person as well
yeah yes he's one of those original
crutches dancers or eureka would say
like there's not many of them in in this
planet right now so there's this one on
him and me so he has like a different
style he works with the crutches they
going under their shoulders yeah
so it's a different style and yeah that
no there was a
other guy he was a just a russian guy he
was like a i don't know five times
medalist in some sports so he was a very
like a famous sports
man and he did actually doing his actual
but when he was injured so they were
like looking for another artist
and i was uh recommended by by some
other
dancers from berlin here that he knows
someone he could probably replace this
act so that's how i
first um there comes the contact between
cirque and me
and the cirque du soleil would you i
mean i've seen the search for solar i
think three times and
and it's it's breathtaking stuff would
you say it's the best circus in the
world
well it's definitely definitely the the
champions league and
in all the entertainment business so
it's if you are once with them like you
have like uh
it's one of the highest class for sure
so it's it's a big honor for every
artist like to work with cirque soleil
okay so on a day-to-day basis what it is
that what is it actually like working
there how tough
is it as an environment yeah how you
know how do you spend your days
because you must be under a lot of
pressure to compete with some very high
class people
well i was lucky that i had a solo act
so i had enough time like you know for
myself
um basically when we are in a city like
we always like staying around
six to eight weeks in one city so you
have also enough time to discover the
cities
so we used to have like uh eight to ten
shows in the week so when you have one
show
you have to ten shows a week yeah that's
a lot it's a lot of work that is tough
that is very tough
it's definitely a lot a lot of work you
know like you need to have to bring some
skills that you are
uh actually can work so long like the
most people like after two three years
there are leaving but
for me it was like just like you know of
a dream just to be worked for them and
like and that's why i did also like six
years for them and that might have
something to do with the fact that you
have said of yourself that there's
something of the traveler in your blood
that you
are somehow a born nomad tell me about
that
well you're smiling definitely i'll i
love to like dancing and also traveling
you know and that
that together is just like a nice mix
together and the cirque is
always like was offering me that thing
it was like you know just
you know open me the doors like also
like and also this was the first time
for me
that i you know were studying something
like they really like teach me how to
like do the makeup
and movement and acrobatics and acting
so there's also like was
a lot of stuff what i was learning from
them you know because before i was just
like
via out of deduct and learning my
teaching myself everything you know
and my skills was just the acrobatic
skills but the rest like now how to
build a show and doing the
choreographies and everything you know
how you can be a part of this business
like
this heart business and i learned a lot
from them i will say
okay uh well then tell me what you have
done with that because you had these six
long years with cirque du soleil now you
are your own man your own manager you're
you're completely independent that's a
very different lifestyle what are you
doing with it what are you doing now
well i'm a one-man business and
everything what i do is manage myself
i'm working now as a freelance worker
so you can hire me for any galas or for
cirque shows i'm doing like
also varieties and stuff like that i
want to also do in the future
i have now time also think about the
future like doing maybe
uh bringing my my biography in a theater
i would like to do my own show
so it's what's really important for me
now uh to making a new progress
to develop myself you know like i think
that i had my six years with cirque du
soleil which was like amazing
but yeah you know i'm not so really i
would not say
i'm good i want to get stuck in the
future you know right now i want to
enjoy the
the moment and just talk about the
forget about the past
and just like let's see what's coming in
the future okay and uh
on the on the report or on the footage
from the cirque du soleil we saw just
that how important it
what formidable sort of upper body
strength and upper body fitness you had
back then is it still the same now where
are you
no definitely yeah i'm i'm working every
day on that so
it's always a it's every day a battle
yeah yeah
definitely as a challenge like to go in
the studio and you know and uh also
work by myself because i used to grow up
in working in a big team
you know so now i'm working by myself
and can be sometimes a little bit hard
but
i can imagine you must have days where
you get up in the morning and think oh
yeah
yeah yeah i mean i spent always like
three to four hours in the gym
like doing my dance routines and going
to choreographies and discovering like
new moves and then after going like to
and working with the weights
okay
what's your relationship to uh
to the word normal well my
my opinion is that we are not all normal
so we all have very individual
so and i see myself like a as
different than other peoples yeah and uh
you know in my my head looks everything
fun
you know and enjoy life is you know life
is short you know and then
i don't want to get stuck with my
situation that okay i'm having a
handicap
and this is it's just too complicated
for me yeah you know my mind looks
everything beautiful i've i
you know you're your own director you
can make it time you can just make it
beautiful you know like
and this gives me energy and gives me
the power what i have you know and
uh this is also what i want to share you
know like so you know and people
think when you have a like you are
sitting in the witcher and the life is
finished but this is
this it's not like that you know like
we're living in a different time in a
new time where
we also can like uh act uh also be
successful
you know and i think it's a it's a very
good story like to show like you know
uh with my story that we can inspire so
many people like you know and
i'm glad that i have this position and
bring this story up
and the and the professor the
sociologist in that report she says that
there was there's one comment where she
says
um there is no such thing
as disability end of story full stop she
says so you would presumably agree with
that
um yeah i mean you are you hold yourself
when uh when uh when you let you stop
yourself you know like in that point you
know and then in that point then you
have you have you have a handicap you
know but when you are actually
going over the hills and just you know
try to take this
uh try to take the the challenge what
someone
gave it to you then you can you can
you can put those heels to the side but
no problem you know like
wonderful i like i like the line that
you had you can be your own director you
can be the
the director for your own movie
effectively um
you went to a school you mentioned
earlier in the discussion you went to a
school for the handicapped the policy in
germany now is to have is moving more
towards having inclusive schools
where people just all go to school
together is that the right way to go
well it's a it's hard to say if it's a
good way or not
you know like definitely when i was a
child i mean if i would like be in one
of those schools i probably would
have a good chance to found a better
jobs you know like so
i think we need to see if this if this
new project
inclusion has a success or not so it's
hard to say on
me but it's a good idea that we are
trying it you know like
and for some people because it's a big
uh
be having a handicap it's a big word you
know like maybe some people have like
just something on the arm or just
something on that on the legs but
they're still in the mind very strong
so why they shouldn't have this
opportunity to like go in a normal
school
you know i think it's a it's a good idea
i like it okay
there's one other thing we haven't
talked about uh again that that is
um you have a german passport right okay
you were born in germany right
you speak better german than turkish no
i speak better german because i was in a
german school okay so better german yeah
you went to school in germany the whole
time yeah yeah
you've got a german driver's license
yeah i do
i know all this because i've researched
it thoroughly yeah but
despite all these things yeah and
despite the fact that you obviously feel
very comfortable living in germany in
very many ways and that augsburg is home
for you
you have been quoted as saying i feel
like i'm
german most of the time what's the most
of the time bit
well i'm an artist you know like and i
like to go in different roles
like so it's when i'm in spain i feel
like spanish if i am turkey i feel like
the
turkish so you know like i i try to
always take the culture
in this in this place where i'm where i
am you know like so
and uh yeah i'm very flexible
you're a wonderful you're a wonderful
optimist and you're a wonderful
role model but you have said something
that i thought was extremely interesting
you said
yourself my greatest challenge has been
the fact that i am somebody from an
immigrant community rather than somebody
who is handicapped
yeah so the bigger challenge in your
life has been being here in germany and
being a member of an immigrant community
that's what you say that's pretty tough
well yeah because the if you compare of
course you now see
like you know because i have his
handicap it must be very hard you know
like but
it wasn't for me like this i'm listening
to everything you say
you know we use always like you know my
parents used to always think to go you
know once we're gonna hear when we are
working we have enough money we're gonna
go back so we always like we grew up in
a kind of like a paralee
world you know you were not really home
in turkey you were not really home in
germany
and this was kind of hard for us as a
child you know like to say hey so where
i'm from now you know like so this
this kind of thing they didn't really
teach it to us so and i think that's why
i also lost myself in dancing so because
i think i'm more more feeling home in
hip-hop
you know than in india in this problem
is what they have here in germany so
so that's why i found really like it was
very difficult for me but i found a
solution
so i found my home and i'm as an artist
it's the language
uh it's doesn't matter from where you
come from the second there
wonderful i i really am impressed and uh
and inspired by your optimism but
there's still one thing i want to know
because your career has been so you've
when you were working for the cirque du
soleil you were you were playing this
role of the limping angel the sort of
the
the fallen angel and i know that while
you were working for the cirque du
soleil you had
there were real down points in your
career because it because you
you had bad falls and you had bad
injuries just tell me a little bit about
that and how you coped with those down
points in your career well in my old
dancing career i think it was the first
time uh
when i was really hurting myself like in
on stage you know like
i mean i had always some little like
accidents where i had some scars here
and there so but
but there like i was like really uh
pushing too much you know and when
you're working with cirque du soleil
you're pushing each other like from with
the artist
and i was definitely just like going too
far you know like because i mean
in that point i was i i didn't have so
much experience you know like
i mean i had the skills as a dancer and
all my my acrobatics but
my experience for like being existing in
in a in a professional entertainment
business
i was just like a rookie so i had to
learn like really
the big knockout with my big injury on
my elbow so
but i think it was a good experience and
now i know more much more better to
appreciate my
my buddy we're talking about your body i
mean uh
and your interest in sport you are
you're into diving
oh yeah yeah
i was in an in australia and uh in great
bear
it was the first time you know like so
with the full suit and uh with the
uh the gas thing i don't know yeah so
and if this was the first time for me
where i like didn't need my legs and i
was like kind of like floating
or like flying in the water so it was a
kind of like
i don't know it was a it was the best
experience what i ever had and
and it was like a dream you were just
like you know
it's incredible wonderful even tougher
than the
diving another thing that's fascinating
but that i i'm going to use a german
word now yeah
you are also into what you call roll
vandan which wheelchair hiking
yeah how does that work well i mean when
you
travel and you're always around and you
have always a different scenario
and i i like to be doing experiments you
know and this was like when i was in new
zealand in oakland
we went to the one of the volcanoes
which was like a hiking way so
i just thought okay maybe it could be
interesting for other wheelchairs
uh drivers maybe you know to inspire
them so i did this video
uh with the wheelchair hiking and uh
yeah it was it was just fun you know it
was like a eight hours
road where you start going to the
volcano and there's
is it was i think it was amazing to see
that fantastic yeah
i mean i had just like lots of blisters
after a while
but yeah it was worth it good for you
right well
we're moving towards the end of the show
we've got our traditional quiz at the
end of the show quick questions quick
answers uh dergan
uh would you rather be at home or on the
road
on the road jay-z or kanye west
kenny west good choice i'm with you all
the way there
um we're talking about the circus yeah
clowns or acrobats
acrobats it had to be didn't it yeah uh
do you prefer perfection or imperfection
imperfection yeah although there's an if
there's a perfectionist inside you
somehow
has life been good to you or tough oh
very good life of stream very well
good for you inspiring person thank you
very much for joining us today great
stuff
that is your lot with the wonderful the
athletic and the very charming dagging
tog mac
a great guest and if you've enjoyed this
company as much as i have come back next
week until then bye-bye
you